[Musik]
alle waren lucca meine damen und herren
herzlich willkommen hier heute zu einem
neuen video auf einem kanal mir wurde in
letzter zeit tausendfach in die
kommentare geschrieben hey luca wenn du
mal etwas richtig sei dass für ein
mäßiges sehen willst also etwas richtig
befriedigendes beruhigendes erfüllendes
dann schau dir das an das ist eine
schrumpelige hand möchte von allen guten
geistern denkt man auf den ersten blick
ist es jedoch gar nicht sondern es ist
das video sma intense glue peeling ja
ich habe uns heute drei videos
rausgesucht die wir uns mal anschauen
werden zu dem ganzen thema und zwar
einmal dass hier mit dieser hand dann
das hier wo auch das kind abgezogen wird
und dass hier
da wird das ist auch kleber hier wird
wirklich häufig in letzter zeit in die
kommentare geschrieben von wegen halo
carlos noch nie auf so einen maus set
ist ein video reagiert wie in die knete
geschnitten wird oder irgendwas anderes
krasses gemacht wird dieses setting
videos sind einfach videos die man sich
anschaut und 90 einfach dabei denkt hey
das ist was was ich gerade auch gern
machen würde
so keine ahnung zu knete kneten ist
einfach ein schönes gefühl
beispielsweise und viele meinen halt
dass diese blume sachen oder irgendwie
wieder auch immer das heißen soll dass
das irgendwie auch sehr interessant und
sehr entspannend beruhigend befriedigend
sein soll befriedigen das glaube ich
ganz ganz falsches wort in dem
zusammenhang in der tat jule also meine
freude hatte mir auch gesagt dass sie
das früher in der schule sehr sehr
häufig gemacht hat irgendwie kleber auf
verhandelt dann nach einer gewissen zeit
abgezogen das hier
ich habe das nie gemacht dass in meiner
schule einfach kein ding ich weiß nicht
mehr habt ihr das früher gemacht
wir haben halt andere sachen früher
gemacht so radiergummis zerschnitten und
er hat noch immer diese biegbaren ideale
damit haben wir ein schwachsinn gemacht
so aber sowas
das ist einfach nur ekelhaft also noch
steht ich weiß nicht was daran bisher
zeigen sein soll das ist ja auch noch
von sma video also sie streicht er die
ganze zeit mit ihren fingern darüber
mich würd sagen jetzt fängt sie an oder
sie grad sie macht einfach so die die
ganze zeit also ich weiß nicht was das
hier für ein erstes video ist ich würde
sagen machen gleich mal direkt weiter
mit dem zweiten video was ich raus
gesucht habe
egal wie können leute auch sowas stehen
und dabei einschlafen doch nun geht es
hier glaube ich los mit dem abziehen
freunde also sie hat jetzt hier diesen
komischen fitzel du musst die nur
anfassen
egal jetzt doch endlich einfach ab
hier zieht sie es nun ab freunde also
mal schauen
sie hat da wirklich falls du dich
versteht das ganz gemacht wird das ist
so ein durchsichtiger kleber sage ich
mal beziehungsweise in vielen fällen
noch ganz normaler kleber denen packt
man sich einfach auf die hand und dann
wird er halt trockenen trocknet sich da
kann man das halt abziehen und das soll
so sein
natürlich alles eine subjektive meinung
also wenn ihr sagt wow das ist voll geil
das ist voll cool ich mal ein
interessantes aus das muss ich den
lassen hier wie die das da abzieht und
jetzt streichelt die da wieder drüber ja
komm
sie ist einfach mal alles update das
schon krass wie hier die haut
hochgezogen wird wird sagen wir noch mal
noch ein bisschen weiter durch also hier
hat jetzt schon ein bisschen mehr
abgezogen wenn ihr sagt hey ich finde
das mega entspannt okay das ist schon
cool aus er ist so cool aus ja okay ich
liebe es zurück wissen es sieht schon es
sieht schon interessant aus ganz
interessante sache
da muss ich wirklich sagen da haben sich
wirklich leute gedacht vertrauen hat jan
haking 300 jahren da gibt's hier
fliegende auto sagen kommt sowas ja
genau hier finde ich wirklich sehr
mysteriös wie sowas von so vielen leuten
gefeiert werden kann ich meine das video
jetzt hier gerade hat gerade mal hundert
tausend aufruf ist auch schon eine menge
aber die anderen wir uns gleich
anschauen werden sie haben über eine
millionen das erinnert mich so ein
bisschen an so kerzenwachs das habe ich
beispielsweise früher auch relativ
häufig gemacht einfach so dem finger
oder den fingernagel in so eine kerze
rein in den wracks und dann halt
trocknen lassen und dann halt
abgezogenen hat seit den finger so seine
gruppe mit wachsenden wunsch das ist
total nostalgiker gerade was man als
kind feuer gemacht hat aber sieht das
also das sieht aus wie ein sehr enger
handschuh den sie an hatte wirklich ein
sehr sehr enge schuhe also sie zieht das
jetzt noch hier den fingern ab hier
fingernagel
ok also real talk ich finds ekelhaft und
verspüren als dass das ganze setting ist
aber dafür mehr noch das hier
das zweite video hier da geht es hier zu
beginn erstmal los dass er seine hand
mit diesem kleber ein klebt immer sieht
man auch wie das ganze funktioniert
ich weiß nicht ob das kriegen wie
schädlich ist ich denke jetzt nicht dass
es so gut für die haut sein wird wenn
man sich da so viel kleber flüssigkeit
draufpackt direkt auf den skin auf jeden
fall ist die linke hand jetzt ein büro
das ist ja das ist so ein bisschen wie
so ein krater alter
liga was a was ist das das sieht ja
viele extreme auswahl sind im ersten
video ikra okay der aber übertreibt hat
auch komplett also der gibt die recht
komplett gas mit seinem abziehen
die in dem ersten video hat das ja so
langsam irgendwie als abgeschüttelt dann
hat die noch ihre hände da getränke
mader
da sieht so aus als wäre ein spinnennetz
von spiderman mutter gefallen also das
sieht echt schon cool aus was muss ich
schon sagen das sieht wirklich so aus
als wäre er als hätte er gerade so seine
alte schicht abgelegt seine alte haut
wie so eine schlange und jetzt kommt die
neue neugeborene schlager kennt das sind
ekelhaft aus das sieht dass sich aus
dieser sprühkleber
ja okay dass er das dass sie tatsächlich
heftig kraft aus gerade der typ ist
komplett crazy der macht dass man auch
sein handy
wahnsinn krass
okay es geht direkt los das ist geil ok
da muss ich wirklich sagen dass sie
glücklich das ist sehr sehr sehr sehr
sehr sehr cool das hätte er mich so ein
bisschen daran wie wenn man so ein neues
handy hat und dann sieht man irgendwie
die folie ab das ist ja auch immer so
ein moment wo man beim iphone den takt
und dann noch mal hinten ein warum tanja
cavs heck ach so das war es ja auch
schönes bild hier gerade allerdings
meine damen und herren habe ich für euch
noch ein weiteres letztes video
vorbereitet die auch eine hand zu sagen
ich mal in kleber gedruckt wurde und
abgezogen wird
ich mache mir direkt auf play das video
schon ein bisschen älter das sieht man
auch an der qualität von der auflösung
et cetera trotz des hat das ganze video
nur 30.000 aufrufe und ist noch relativ
unbekannt ist der kanal hat auch nur
7000 abonnenten ist ich fand es aber
sehr schön also das finde ich wirklich
das ist ein video wo man wirklich am
krassesten sieht okay es könnte auch
sein zieht er gerade seine haut ab hat
euch leider keinen ton grad einfügen
weil das copyright ist also ich habe
keine rechte an der musik aber da hört
man auch sonst nix die sache sich halt
einmal ganz kurz innehalten um so oh
mein gott der krabbeltiere die ganze
zeit bei seiner hand hat sie hier vorne
ist wirklich so ein insekt das läuft ja
so die ganze zeit lang bei seiner hand
in zentraler lage nicht ob da war sogar
derart die fans kein bisschen drüber
besser auch egal erzählt auf jeden fall
seiner hand ich fange schon sagen seine
hand ab er zieht er den kleber von
seiner hand ab da vorne mal wieder das
insekt felix da wahnsinn wirklich freude
das ist komplett irre das sieht richtig
geiles wieder dafür seinen finger so
landen lang abziehen das ist dass ich
schon
also ich bin ganz echt das erste video
war komplette scheiße finde ich egal
schießt doch endlich einfach abwahl zu
arzt am ermäßigt apple noch ein bisschen
meine hand roma bisschen geräusche mit
meinem schreibtisch aber das hier also
wirklich das sieht ein bisschen ekelhaft
aus aber ich glaube das ist ganz ganz
ganz cooles gefühl wenn man das so er
den finger ab zieht das ist schon das
ist also wirklich von von beginn an da
war ich überhaupt so denkst was das mit
der scheiße jetzt gerade es ist schon
cool erzählt hier weiter seine haut ab
ich sage wieder er zieht seine haut aber
jetzt sind ja eigentlich nur den kleber
ab und es ist auch eigentlich eine
komplett normale situation so erlebt
macht sich kleber auf die hand und zieht
danach den kleber abschluss ist ja
völlig völlig normal das ist das was
jeder als kind jeden tag in der schule
gemacht hat anscheinend früher aber es
sieht wirklich mega cool aus da läuft
die ganze noch und
denkt drüber ich verstehe nicht warum er
das nicht einfach mal entfernen und dann
wenn man so wächst oder so aber
wahrscheinlich möchte den sektor nicht
wehtun oder so aber krass ich finde es
auch heftig wie perfekt das wirklich
abgeht wir sehen hier keine löcher
irgendwie in dem kleber oder so das
lässt sich perfekt hier alles genau
abziehen
liga
barbie er hat ihnen welche tipps wie man
sich die fußpilz entfernen auch noch
menschen nicht gesenkt ziemlich abstoßen
also das ganze ist wirklich eine sehr
sehr interessante thematik ich hab ich
das jetzt einfach noch mal in zweifacher
geschwindigkeit abspielen lassen hier im
hintergrund
das sieht schon dass sich schon
besonders dass sie das sieht schon ultra
ultra krass aus ich finds halt wirklich
krank wie das einfach perfekt ab geht
also ich kenne das nur ich hasse das
auch wenn man irgendwie sich ein produkt
kauft und da ist dann noch der barcode
hinten drauf sind das preisschild und
das muss man so abstimmen das ist
richtig kacke da freut man sich wirklich
wenn das einfach so saxe des verein
komplett alles auf einmal abgeht und
hier das sieht genauso aus halte ich
hätte ich hätte wirklich ried ob
mittlerweile echt bock das ganze mal
selbst gemacht wenn ihr wollt dass ich
das ganze eventuell auch mattes und mit
diesen speziellen kleber ich weiß gar
nicht oder ob es nun mit jedem normalen
kleber auch gehen wenn ich das einfach
mal selbst testen soll dann lasst einen
like darum meine damen und herren bei
40.000 like werde ich demnächst auch so
ein video hochladen ich bin anfang
dezember erstmal in new york das heißt
wahrscheinlich danach aber 40.000 like
sollte das zeigt mir hey leute hält
nämlich hey leute sondern herr luca
macht das mal dann werde ich mich der
wissenschaft opfern ich packe einfach
nur kleber auf meiner hand aber ja meine
damen und herren wenn euch dieses video
heute gefallen hat das geld über einen
like da wirklich zu beginn so da dachte
ich mir so henn assistentin ich heiße
aber jetzt zum ende hin dass allein der
sieg das sieht schon echt cool aus
schreibt mir gern mal sachen in die
kommentare die ihr als kind in der
schule gemacht habt beziehungsweise wenn
ihr noch in der schule seit eventuell
immer noch täglich in der schule macht
vielleicht macht er auch so ein
schwachsinn wie handvoll kleben und das
abziehen start zu gehen und in die
kommentare und jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]